I mean so what's it like when you when
you work with someone like really Scott
I tell you it's as good as it gets
because I'm a filmmaker driven guy I
mean I I grew up watching movies with my
dad
old-school you know filmmaker driven you
know blue-collar actors to be able to
work for somebody who I've seen in
passing for 20-some odd years I had
always been a huge fan of and then to
kind of get the call saying that he
wants to work with me it's it's pretty
special you know this he's the kind of
guy where you know you'll sit and watch
an interview of Gary Oldman is somebody
talking about making a Ridley Scott
movie and what it's like to be on set
and how he kind of conducts the set and
composed the shots and all that stuff it
kind of jealous you know and then to be
able to be there I was giddy I was like
a little kid I mean and then say to go
through that experience and then have
the film jeopardized by the Kevin Spacey
situation I mean what kind of thoughts
and emotions come with that you know
it's tough I mean I've been doing this
for a long time a lot of times you know
you make a movie and you think it's
something and it turns out that it
doesn't it doesn't live up to the
expectations or you know a studio
somebody won't support it this is the
first time where it was ever in jeopardy
because of something that somebody did
or was accused of doing and so that was
different for me but I always feel like
you know certain things are out of your
control and I have to be able to accept
that I'm just always trying to make the
best possible movie and I want it to be
the best success for everybody involved
and it's never for lack of effort
sometimes it doesn't turn out that way
but to see really kind of say you know
this is my movie and I'm not going to
let 800 people's hard work just kind of
get scrapped we're going to go and
recast it we're gonna redo the movie and
the movies going to come out and we're
going to celebrate everybody's hard work
it was pretty incredible to see him to
be able to do that at the pace with the
vigor that he did I mean the guy's 80
years old and he moves
a stealth bomber I mean it's incredible
so very impressive and you know then I
got to go back and spend more time with
him and pick his brain even more and it
was it was incredible yeah obviously you
know I wanted to make sure that we would
continue to go out and voice our concern
for the people were victimized
across the board and that's the most
important thing but to also then have
you know people who worked really hard
and you know good hard-working people
have that kind of work scrapped that was
that was a tough pill to swallow
Michelle Williams is phenomenal phone
you know she got a nomination for this
as well what do you think about her
performance it was like work alongside
her she's fantastic I mean to kind of go
in you know we've got to spend the whole
time together so we spent a lot of time
we've said the same hotel we were
talking about where we're gonna eat and
you know what her preteen was doing and
my teenager was doing and all that stuff
and then you know just prepared you know
kind of be able to relax chill out and
then we're on we're on and we're off you
know I'm just kind of talking it's nice
but you know you're again you're working
with people that are very prepared and
you know when they get that moment
they're gonna they're gonna capitalize
on it